[Music]
wrist stretches for iikido practice. So
before you begin your Iikido practice
for the day, it might be a really good
idea to go through and stretch your
wrists a little bit to get ready for
what you're about to go through. Um, and
also this is a practice you can do in
your own maybe before you go to bed at
night to really help strengthen up the
tendons in your arm and get a little
more flexibility and strength in the
joints. So the way you can go one of the
ways you can go through all the
stretches would be like this. So I
usually start with sio. I turn my elbow
up and palm out. I reach over with my
other hand and grab palm to palm and
twist the thumb away from me. You can
see now I'm applying a sono to myself.
Whenever you're doing a sono, you don't
want to be applying sono with your
thumb. You want to apply it with your
whole hand. So go palm to palm and twist
the thumb away from yourself. Now I'm
applying sono to myself. Next would be
nikio. So niko, a good way to get the
idea is to make a ring out of your index
finger and your thumb. Place that ring
against the flat of your other hand.
Pull your wrist back and your elbow
forward. So you can see in this I'm
pushing my elbow forward as my wrist is
coming back. And I'm going to get a
stretch all through here which is the
nikio stretch. So make a ring out of
your index finger and your thumb flat of
your hand. Pull your wrist back. Push
your elbow forward. This is nikio. Next
be kodash. Kodash. I'm going to turn
palm towards my face. Reach around and
grab the base of my thumb with my four
fingers. Don't use your thumb to twist
the pinky away from you. Use the whole
palm of your hand. Twist your thumb away
and your pinky towards your face. You
can see here I'm applying a kodak to
myself. So palm towards my face. Reach
around and grab the base of the thumb.
Twist the thumb away and sink it down
right in front of your chest. I'm
applying kodish to myself. Next would be
gokyo. So gokyo. I bring my hand right
in front of my face, palm down. Reach on
top with my other hand, putting the palm
of my hand against the back of my other
hand. Grab my wrist and push my uh wrist
down. At the same time, I can push my
elbow down on the other side. and I'm
applying gokyo to myself. So, hand in
front, palm down, grab the wrist, push
the palm down, push the elbow down, and
I'm applying gokyo to myself. Uh, this
is not so much a stretch, but just if
you want to kind of get the idea, you
can also do yono by bringing the hand
palm up in front of myself, reaching
across, applying the knuckle of my index
finger right on the the bone here, and
push straight in. And I'll apply yono to
myself. So, this kind of gives you an
idea of how you can do Yonko and how it
feels on other people. So, going through
these really quickly before you begin
Iikido practice is a good way to get
yourself ready and your wrist particular
ready for what you're about to do. The
Iikido wrist stretches.